[Applaus]
[Musik]
seit einem Monat hat Argentinien einen
neuen Präsidenten der libertäre ja milei
ist aber nicht irgendein Präsident es
ist wohl das erste Mal in der gesamten
Weltgeschichte dass in einem Land ein
eindeutig libertärer Präsident an die
Macht gekommen ist ein Mann der sich
selbst zum Feind des Staates erklärt hat
und von allem was mit staatlichen
Eingriffen zu tun hat und nur wenige
Wochen im Amt macht er deutlich dass
seine Wahlversprechen keine leeren Worte
waren nein er ist ein Mann der Taten
meleay beginnt mit der Demontage des
argentinischen Staates nachdem er 300
Reformen in einem einzigen Dekret
durchsetzt Argentiniens melei feuert
5000 Staatsbedienstete kavier mi
entlässt 22 armeegeneräle im Rahmen der
größten Umstrukturierung des Militärs
seit 20 Jahren m erweist sich als der
schlimmste Albtraum des wen bestens
meleay hat sowohl mit seinen
Ankündigungen als auch nun mit seinen
prompten Reformen alle möglichen
Reaktionen hervorgerufen aber vor allem
zwei haben sich ja vorgetan diejenigen
die ihn für ein Jünger Donald Trumps
halten und diejenigen die ihn für einen
rechtsextrempolitiker halten wir
sprechen von einem Mann dessen Karriere
kometenhaft verlief vom praktisch
unbekannten Wirtschaftsprofessor stieg
er bin weniger Jahre bis an die
Staatsspitze auf und er wurde nicht
irgendein Präsident sondern ein
Präsident der mit einem völlig
bahnbrechenden Versprechen an die Macht
kam nämlich das gesamte wirtschaftliche
politische und soziale System
Argentiniens komplett umzukrempeln mit
anderen Worten mele kommt als ein Art
bulldoer mit einer ebenso klaren wie
ergeizigen Mission die Grundlagen des
Peronismus ein für alle Mal zu zerstören
und das größte Kunststück daran ist dass
B ist nicht nur als völliger unbekannter
geschafft hat Präsident zu werden
sondern auch ohne eine der historischen
politischen formation Argentiniens
anzugehören er gründete nämlich einfach
seine eigene Partei la libertat avanza
die Freiheit schreitet voran wie ihr
gesehen habt gibt es viele Medien
Analysten und Politiker die ihn
beschuldigen Teil der extremen Rechten
zu sein aber kann man dies wirklich so
sagen ist m tatsächlich Teil der
extremen Rechten und warte denn das ist
noch nicht alles wie wir bereits erwähnt
haben wird er auch mit bolsonaro Victor
Orban und Donald Trump verglichen er ist
ganz klar ein Mini Trump Trump ist eine
Ikone dieser neuen Form des extremen
Populismus und m will ihn nacheifern die
Frage lautet also inwieit ähnelt JAV m
Donald Trump jair bolsonaro oder sogar
Victor Orban hatte argentinische Löwe
wirklich so viele Gemeinsamkeiten mit
dem ehemaligen Präsidenten der USA dem
ehemaligen Präsidenten Brasiliens und
dem Ministerpräsidenten Ungarns nun wenn
man sich Nachrichten wie die folgende
anschaut scheint es so als hätte er eine
Menge mit Ihnen gemeinsam Donald Trump
ist einer der wenigen die den Kampf
gegen den Sozialismus verstanden haben
jaav vielen Dank Präsident Trump ihre
Präsidentschaft war ein Vorbild für uns
alle die wir die Ideen der Freiheit
verteidigen und ich hoffe Sie bald zu
treffen habe keinen Zweifel daran dass
wir Argentinien wieder groß machen
werden via la libertat cararajo unsere
geopolitische Ausrichtung sind die USA
und Israel das ist unsere internationale
Politik wir werden uns nicht mit
Kommunisten verbünden und dennoch meine
Lieben Zuschauer sollten wir uns nicht
zu voreiligen Schlüssen verleiten lassen
herzlichen Glückwunsch an zu einer
großartigen Wahl zum Präsidenten
Argentiniens die ganze Welt hatzugesehen
und ich bin sehr stolz auf euch ihr
werdet euer Land umkrempeln und
Argentinien wieder groß
machen ich bin sicher dass Gott euch
erleuchten und beschützen wird und ihr
eine gute Regierungsarbeit zum Wohle
unserer Länder leisten
werdet ja es ist wahr D eine klare
üereinstimmung im erkennen können sowohl
B als auch Trump bolsonaro und sogar
Orban neigen zu einem sehr rauen Ton sie
sind aggressiv und positionieren sich
alle als Alternative zum System in
gewisser Weise haben Sie alle einen
populistischen Touch sie alle zeichnen
sich dadurch aus dass sie sich einen
Gegner einen Feind aussuchen dass sie
sich als Star gebieren und eine fast
wundersame Maßnahme hervorheben die sie
dann bis zum Überdruss wiederholen und
dass sie sich dabei meist mit den Medien
anlegen vom Standpunkt der politischen
Botschaft ausgesehen sind Trumps
Einwanderer dasselbe wie M Klassen aber
wisst ihr was das war's auch schon mit
den Gemeinsamkeiten die Wahrheit ist
nämlich dass M in den großen Fragen in
der Positionierung und der politischen
Agenda Trump Orban und bolsonaro so
ähnlich ist wie ein Ei einer Kastanie
bis zu einem gewissen Grad hat er mit
Trump bolsonaro und Orban also viele
Ähnlichkeiten allerdings ist
Argentiniens neuer Präsident nun sagen
wir einfach er gehört einem ganz anderen
Club an ihr glaubt mir nicht denkt ihr
etwa ich übertreibe nun falls ihr das
denkt dann lasst uns mit einem Vergleich
zwischen Xavier m und Donald Trump
beginnen und passt gut auf denn wir
reden hier über die sieben
gravierendsten politischen Unterschiede
zwischen diesen beiden
Führungspersönlichkeiten zwei Politikern
die in ihrem Kern nicht
unterschiedlicher sein könnten lasst uns
aber bevor wir sie so richtig auseinand
nehmen noch unserem Sponsor in cogni
danken der das heutige Video erst
möglich gemacht hat ein Sponsor der euch
zu dem aktiv vor Datenmissbrauch durch
sogenannte data Broker schützen kann
databroker sind datenmakler die unsere
persönlichen Daten überall im Netz
abgreifen und danach nicht nur an
seriöse Unternehmen verkaufen sondern
auch an Betrüger diese Betrüger
bombardieren uns dann mit unerwünschten
Anrufen SMS und E-Mails oder versuchen
uns sogar auszunehmen Nachteile durch
die Verbreitung deiner Daten müssen die
aber nicht erst durch Betrüger erwachsen
hast du dir schon mal überlegt wer alles
aus deinen Daten im Netz Rückschlüsse
ziehen könnte teilweise sind diese ja
sogar falsch oder stellen falsche
Interpretationen deines Verhaltens im
Netz da und dann wunderst du dich warum
du z. Beel vom neuen Arbeitgeber oder
Vermieter abgelehnt wirst plötzlich
höhere Versicherungsbeiträge zahlen
musst oder kein Kredit von der Bank
bekommst und zwar ohne dass du den
wahren Grund dafür jemals erfährst ganz
genau leider haben wir keinerlei
Kontrolle darüber an wen alles die
databoker unsere Daten verkaufen und was
Ihre Kunden dann daraus gegen uns
stricken aber es gibt zum Glück einen
Ausweg aus diesem Albtraum die databoker
sind nämlich gesetzlich dazu
verpflichtet unsere Daten zu löschen
wenn wir sie dazu auffordern das Problem
dabei es gibt Tausende von ihnen und oft
ist der Antragsprozess absichtlich
kompliziert gestaltet deswegen
resignieren viele Menschen einfach und
lassen den ganzen Schmu passiv über sich
ergehen der Sponsor dieses Videos
incogni bietet genau dafür jedoch eine
Lösung incogni übernimmt die Aufgabe bei
den databrokern für dich aufzuräumen und
stellt deine Löschanträge mehr noch
falls die databoker deine Daten dann
nicht freiwillig löschen setzt incogni
die Löschung sogar rechtlich durch und
das beste alles was du dafür tun musst
ist Dich bei incogni anzumelden sie mit
der Durchsetzung der Löschanträge zu
beauftragen und dann verfolgst du bequem
auf einem übersichtlichen Dashboard wie
deine Daten nach und nach aus dem Netz
verschwinden und ich sage dir das ist
einfach ein herrliches Gefühl ohne einen
solchen Service wäre es für einen
normalen Menschen nah zuu unmöglich
diese Löschanträge selbst zu bearbeiten
und sich so vor Betrug zu schützen also
du was gutes für deine datenhygiene und
schau dir incogni jetzt gleich über den
Link in der Videobeschreibung an denn
mit unserem exklusiven Promocode
politikd hältst du auch noch satte 60%
Rabatt und wenn du das erledigt hast
lass uns nach Argentinien reisen um zu
ergründen wer
wirklich
ist die
handelsmauer okay ich denke wir alle
wissen dass dieses Thema neben der
Einwanderung eines der großen
Markenzeichen des 45 Präsidenten der USA
ist und es ist auch der erste große
Unterschied den wir zu mil feststellen
können Trump ist ein eingefleischter
protektionist das gleiche könnte man in
ge Wissen Maße auch über bolsonaro und
Orban sagen diese drei politiker
sprechen andauernd davon die lokale
Industrie zu fördern Lokal hergestellte
Produkte zu kaufen und so weiter und so
fort tatsächlich ist der Freihandel
eines der Themen die Trump zuerst in die
Politik gelockt haben schon in den 80er
Jahren trat er in Fernsehsendungen auf
und prangerte an dass Japan die USA mit
seinen Exporten ausplündern würde als er
2015 seine Kandidatur für die
republikanischen Vorwahlen ankündigte
stellte er deshalb den Handel genau in
den Mittelpunkt seiner Kampagne China
bringt uns um das Geld das sie aus den
USA abgezogen haben ist der größte
Diebstahl in der Geschichte unseres
Landes und als ein Oval Office
platznahmen legte er sofort los Trump
hat einen Handelskrieg gegen die
Europäische Union begonnen er zog die
USA aus dem TPP den größten
Freihandelsabkommen der Geschichte
heraus er startete einen großen
Handelskrieg gegen China und verhängte
haufenweise Zölle und er drote wirklich
allen mit wirtschaftlichen
Vergeltungsmaßnahmen am Ende war das
Ergebnis all dieser Maßnahmen jedoch ein
Misserfolg das Handelsdefizit wuchs
weiter und mehrere Studien zufolge
kostete der Handelskrieg amerikanische
Haushalte Milliarden von Dollar und
vernichtete mehr als 200.000
Arbeitsplätze aber darüber haben wir
bereits in einem anderen Video
gesprochen dass ich euch verlinken werde
und okay einige von euch werden jetzt
vielleicht sagen ja er war gegen das
eine oder das andere aber es ist doch
nicht so dass er wirklich gegen den
Freihandel war oder nun jetzt kandidiert
Trump erneut bei den Vorwahlen der
Republikaner und ratet mal was eine
seiner wichtigsten Botschaften ist Trump
verspricht massive neue Zölle wenn er
gewählt wird und riskiert damit einen
globalen Wirtschaftskrieg und natürlich
denken einige von euch jetzt da haben
wir es die Presse manipuliert schon
wieder seine Worte aber schaut euch doch
einfach an was er selbst gesagt hat ich
finde wenn Unternehmen in die USA kommen
und ihre Produkte dort Abladen sollten
Sie automatisch eine Steuer von sagen
wir 10% zahlen ganz genau wir reden
darüber dass Trump einen allgemeinen
Zoll von etwa 10% auf alle Produkte die
in die USA eingeführt werden befürwort
um euch eine Vorstellung davon zu geben
das wäre mehr als das Dreifache des
durchschnittszolls der derzeit unter 3%
liegt und die Frage ist was sagt m zu
diesem Thema nun im Grunde das genaue
Gegenteil mil will Argentiniens Grenzen
für den internationalen Handel
vollkommen öffnen in seinem
Regierungsprogramm hat er sich
verpflichtet Zölle und alle anderen
Beschränkung des internationalen Handels
einschließlich Quoten Genehmigungen und
Zulassung abzuschaffen er hat sogar
Dinge wie diese über den Mercosur gesagt
ich denke ihr müsst den Mercosur
abschaffen denn er ist eine Union mit
fehlerhaften Zollverfahren die den guten
Argentiniern Schaden mit anderen Worten
es handelt sich im Grunde um eine
handelsunion die von den Staaten
verwaltet wird um fetternwirtschaft zu
betreiben ihr seht also das ist der
erste große Unterschied aber lasst uns
[Musik]
weitermachen macht die Zentralbank
dicht
meine Lieben Zuschauer wenn wir vorhin
gesagt haben dass Protektionismus ein
Kennzeichen des trumpismus ist wird wohl
niemand auch nur den geringsten Zweifel
daran haben dass die Abschaffung der
Zentralbank damit Politiker sie nicht
manipulieren können eines der großen
politischen Markenzeichen mes ist
tatsächlich hat der neue argentinische
Präsident die dollarisierung und die
Schließung der Zentralbank zu seinem
wichtigsten Anliegen gemacht dafür hat
er sich immer wieder weement eingesetzt
schaut es euch
an
[Musik]
der argentinischen Wirtschaft
verantwortlich angefangen bei der
Inflation vielleicht sollte man aber
auch erwähnen dass er vor allem die
Politiker dafür verantwortlich macht
dass sie sich immer wieder in die
Geschäfte der Zentralbank einmischen und
sie dazu missbrauchen ihre Launen zu
finanzieren und Staatsschulden zu
monetarisieren laut m hat genau das den
Peso und Argentiniens Finanzen zerstört
und wisst ihr was Trump befürwortet im
Grunde genommen das Gegenteil ganz genau
ihr habt mich richtig
verstanden
einer von Trumps großen und ständigen
Kritikpunkten während seiner Zeit im
Weißen Haus war die Unabhängigkeit der
Federal Reserve Trump hat ständig
versucht sie unter Druck zu setzen mehr
Geld zu drucken die Zinsen zu senken und
sogar die Staatsschulden zu
monetarisieren die Federal Reserve
sollte unsere Zinssätze auf Null oder
weniger senken und dann sollten wir
beginnen unsere Schulden zu
refinanzieren wir wissen dass ich viel
Lobbyarbeit gemacht habe es war Druck
von außen denn niemand weiß ob man das
wirklich tun kann kan oder nicht ich
habe es getan weil ich fand dass ihre
Zinssätze so hoch waren und schließlich
haben sie ihre Zinsen gesenkt und
vergisst bitte nicht dass die Zinssätze
ihren höhstand bei 2inhal% erreichten
während die US-Wirtschaft in einem guten
Tempo wuchs und trotzdem beschwerte sich
Trump und setzte die Fett immer wieder
unter Druck na versteht ihr jetzt wie
die inflationskrise entstanden ist
tatsache ist dass der ehemalige
Präsident das alles während seiner Zeit
im Weißen Haus getan hat und es jetzt
als Kandidat bei den Vorwahlen der
Republikaner wiedertut 15 September 2023
Trump beklagt hohe zinsätze und deutet
an dass er die Fett zu einer Senkung
drängen könnte Unabhängigkeit der
Zentralbank ha geldtcken das war eines
der großen Zugpferde Trumps denn er
wusste genau dass es kurzfristig die
Wirtschaft ankurbeln würde was sein
Beliebtheitsgrad steigert und vergess
nicht das sagen nicht nur wir das hat er
selbst gesagt die Leute können keine
Häuser kaufen Sie können nichts tun ich
meine sie können sich kein Geld leihen
ich erinnere euch noch einmal daran dass
wir von Zinssätzen um die 2% sprechen
und es ist auch egal ob ihr es für
besser oder schlechter haltet mis
Meinung dazu ist genau das Gegenteil
kein weiteres geldrucken keine
künstliche aufbelegung der
Volkswirtschaft und keine
Monetarisierung der Staatsschulden also
ein ziemlich großer Unterschied zu Trump
findet Ihr nicht aber wartet wir sind
noch lange nicht fertig tatsächlich hat
Trumps beharen darauf dass die Fetti
Geldmenge erhöht viel mit den folgenden
beiden Punkten zu
tun das Feuer mit Benzin
löschen
okay sowohl Trump als auch melee aber
auch bolsonar und Orban sprechen von
Steuersenkungen das mag theoretisch ein
gemeinsamer Punkt sein denn noch gibt es
einen grundlegenden Unterschied Mili
will die Steuern senken und die dadurch
sinken Staatseinnahmen durch
Ausgabenkürzungen ausgleichen in Trumps
Fall war das jedoch etwas anders Trump
wollte vor allem dass die Fett die
Zinsen senkt mehr Geld druckt und mehr
Staatsschulden aufkauft um sein
wachsendes Defizit zu finanzieren
tatsächlich ist der jährliche Anstieg
des Defizits während seiner Amtszeit der
größte Anstieg im Verhältnis Z größ der
Wirtschaft unter allen Präsidenten in
der Geschichte der USA gewesen er steht
damit in einer Reihe mit George
Washington und Abraham Lincoln aber mit
einem großen Unterschied Trump musste
sich während seiner Amtszeit nicht mit
großen Kriegen innerhalb des Landes
auseinandersetzen sagen wir einfach dass
der ehemalige amerikanische Präsident
die Staatsausgaben Jahr für Jahr steigen
ließ während er gleichzeitig die Steuern
senkte und die dadurch entstandene
Haushaltslücke war enorm um euch eine
Vorstellung davon zu geben als 2016 ins
weißer Haus einzog lag das Defizit bei
2,5%. und nach 3 Jahren Trump 2019 hatte
das Defizit 4,6% erreicht obwohl das
Land während dieser Zeit wuchs und die
Pandemie noch nicht da war Trump hatte
es vollkommen versäumt während der Zeit
des Wirtschaftswachstums für schlechte
Zeiten vorzusorgen und das ist ein
weiterer wichtiger Unterschied denn für
melei hat das Nulldefizit und die
Reduzierung der öffentlichen Ausgaben
Priorität denn wie wir alle wissen sind
die schlechten Zeiten ja dann auch
gekommen
[Musik]
der
Schuldenberg in nur 4er Jahren
Regierungszeit sind die Staatsschulden
unter Donald Trump um fast 7,8 Billionen
Dollar gestiegen das sind mehr als
000$ pro Einwohner es ist einfach
verrückt und nicht nur das als dann die
Pandemie ausbrach zeigte Trump deutlich
wie er mit einer Krise umzugehen gedenkt
nämlich indem er ohne Reserven gebildet
zu haben weiter tonnenweise öffentliche
Gelder ausgibt er ging sogar s weit dass
er schcks an alle Bürger schickte also
natürlich nicht er persönlich sondern
die staatskkasse tatsächlich überstieg
allein die Reaktion der US
Bundesregierung auf die covid-krise nach
Trumps Plan 8% des BIP zum Vergleich
zwischen 1933 und 39 stiegen die
Bundesausgaben unter rooswelts
kolossalem New Deal um etwa 5% des BIP
und die Maßnahmen gegen die große
Finanzkrise und Rezession von 2008
kosteten 3% das Ergebnis von Trumps
Amtszeit war also vor allem ein
gigantischer noch nie da gewesener
Schuldenberg noch einmal unabhängig
davon ob i diese Maßnahmen nun
befürwortet oder nicht es ist nicht Ziel
dieses Videos sie zu bewerten der Punkt
ist jedoch dass Trumps Politik wieder
einmal in die entgegengesetzte Richtung
zu dem geht was be
fürürwortet
und vor allem geht es darum wie Trump
das riesige Haushaltsloch finanzierte er
setzte einfach die Zentralbank unter
Druck die Zinsen zu senken und
stahsanleihen zu kaufen in dieser
Hinsicht Inel Trumps Schritte eher den
von Sergio Massa als den von jaier M
also weder beim zentralbankwesen noch
bei der Frage wie man Steuern senken
kann noch bei der Höhe der
Staatsausgaben bei der
Staatsverschuldung noch beim
internationalen Handel haben m und Trump
gemeinsame Position wie ihr sehen könnt
befinden sie sich viel mehr an den exakt
entgegengesetzten Enden des Spektrums
aber warte den natürlich geht es nicht
nur um die
Wirtschaft
[Musik]
Abtreibung mi ist sehr deutlich und
nimmt kein Blatt vor den Mund er sagt
dass Abtreibung Mord sei und ist
vehement dagegen er hat sogar eine
Referendum angekündigt um die 2020 in
beschlossen Legalisierung rückgängig zu
machen ich bin ganz offen gegen
Abtreibung weil sie gegen das Recht auf
Leben verstößt der neue argentinische
Präsident ist s weit gegangen dass er
Menschen die für Abtreibung sind eine
Gehirnwäsche durch eine mörderische
Politik unterstellt hat und was ist mit
Donald Trump nun sagen wir einfach dass
er keine so klare Position hat und es
scheint auch keine Priorität für ihn
darzustellen im Jahr 1999 verteidigte er
z.B öffentlich das Recht der Frauen
selbst zu entscheiden ich bin sehr für
die Abtreibung ich hasse das Konzept der
Abtreibung ich hasse sie ich hasse alles
wofür sie steht ich erschaudere wenn ich
Leuten zuhöre die über dieses Thema
diskutieren aber ich glaube einfach an
die Wahlfreiheit das heißt in diesem
Punkt ist Trump der liberale dies ist im
Übrigen eine ganz ähnliche Position wie
die Joe bidens zwar rühmt sich Trump
damit dass unter seiner Regierung
konservative Richter in den obersten
Gerichtshof gewählt wurden und dass
dadurch das richtungsweisende Urteil row
vs Wight aus dem Jahr 73 dass das Recht
der Frau auf Abtreibung anerkannte zu
Fall gebracht wurde und dass dieses
Thema nun in die Zuständigkeit der
Bundesstaaten verlagert wurde aber das
hat er V allem deswegen weil er weiß
dass es sich nicht leisten kann die
Unterstützung vieler konservativer
Kreise zu verlieren denn gleichzeitig
weigert sich Trump eine nationale
Beschränkung zu unterstützen und
tatsächlich finden wir in seiner
Kampagne Botschaften wie diese Trump
nenn des sent des Abtreibungsverbot
einen schrecklichen Fehler und zieht
damit den Zorn einiger wichtige
Republikaner auf sich daraufin zögerte
die sentes nicht folgendes zu erwidern
ich weiß nicht wie ihr überhaupt
behaupten könnt dass ihr für das Leben
seid wenn ihr Staaten dafür kritisiert
dass sie Schutzmaßnahmen für Babys mit
Herzschlag erlassen haben ihr seht also
bei diesem Thema gehören mi und Trump
vollkommen unterschiedlichen Lagern an
aber lasst uns
[Musik]
weitermachchen niemand kommt
rein okay wenn wir vorhin gesagt haben
dass Protektionismus einer der grundpile
des trumpismus ist können wir auch sagen
dass Einwanderung das andere große
marktenzeichen ist Trump will keine
Einwanderer egal welche Art er tritt
dafür ein die illegale Einwanderung zu
beenden aber auch die legale
Einwanderung einzuschränken und zu
begrenzen die Art und Weise wie er über
Menschen spricht die aus dem Ausland
kommen ist nicht gerade einladend und
wenn ihr euch seine Kandidatur für 2024
genau anseht geht es genau darum die
illegale wie die legale Einwanderung
weiter einzuschränken es überrascht
daher nicht dass er über die Abschiebung
von Millionen von Menschen spricht
habimili Position hingegen ist wieder
mal vollkommen anders er ist
konzeptionell und ideologisch für ein
viel offeneres einwanderungssystem
seiner Meinung nach sind die Kosten für
die Sozialleistung das einzige Problem
bei der Einwanderung es gibt Dokumente
die belegen dass es in den Ländern die
offener sind mehr Innovation und
Wachstum gibt also ist Einwanderung eine
gute Sache als unsere Großeltern und
Eltern kamen kamen sie um im Schweiße
ihres Angesichts ihr Brot zu verdienen
und es gab keinen Sozialstaat das
Problem mit der Einwanderung entsteht
wenn es einen wohlfahrtsst gibt deshalb
hat er gesagt dass er eine freizügige
und offene einwanderungsregelung
praktisch unterstützen würde wenn es z.B
ein allgemeines Gutscheinsystem oder ein
privates Unterstützungssystem gebe auch
das ist eine Position die im Widerspruch
zu Trump steht aber jetzt haltet euch
fest denn wir haben noch einen letzten
Punkt die Ukraine und die
Tyrannen ja einige Male hat M gesagt
dass er Trumps Auen politische Vision
unterstütze aber wenn wir ins Detail
gehen sieht die ganze Sache schon wieder
ganz anders aus diejenigen von uns die
ohne Zögern ein Modell der offenen und
freien Gesellschaft verteidigen müssen
sich für eine wirksame Strategie
zusammenschließen um den Feinden der
Freiheit entgegenzutreten die wie in der
Vergangenheit erneut versuchen die
Menschen in dunkle Zeiten des Chaos und
des Elends zurückzuziehen so unterstützt
Mili sowohl die Ukraine als auch Israel
während Trump damit droht die Hilfe für
Kiev zu stoppen
Glückwunsch an Javier m zu seinem
überzeugenden Sieg bei den
argentinischen Präsidentschaftswahlen
ich schätze seine klare Haltung zur
Unterstützung der Ukraine ich freue mich
auf die Zusammenarbeit um unsere
Kooperation zu stärken und die
internationale Ordnung auf der Grundlage
des Völkerrechts wiederherzustellen wol
mir selenski selenski ist der Stargast
bei mis Amtseinführung unter den
ausländischen Staatsoberhäuptern die an
der Amtseinführung von RAV in Buenos
Aires teilnahmen Staren zwei besonders
hervor ganz oben auf der Liste stand der
ukrainische Präsident vol selenski der
bei der Abwehr der russischen Invasion
dringend auf Hilfe aus dem Ausland
angewiesen ist der andere war jair
bolsonaro der obwohl er nicht mehr
Präsident Brasiliens ist von der neuen
argentinischen Regierung bevorzugt
behandelt wurde m ist eindeutig
proestliche und proreiheitliche
Ausrichtung könnte klarer nicht sein K
mi kzelt bricksbeitritt die
brickstaatengruppe will ein Gegengewicht
zum Westen sein Argentinien hätte 2024
beitreten sollen aber nun macht KV mi
ein Rückzieher der frisch gewählte
anachapital orientiert sich an den USA
und Israel und lasst uns bitte
Begegnungen wie die folgende nicht
vergessen ihr erinnert euch doch sicher
noch alle daran
oder Trump sagt Nordkoreas Kim sei sehr
ehrenhaft und was sagt m dazu nun im
Wesentlichen dass er absolut nichts mit
Autoritarismus oder Kommunismus zu tun
haben will denn selbst wenn man sich auf
privater Ebene einigermaßen versteht
geht auf Staatsebene sowas gar nicht ich
würde mich nicht für Beziehungen mit
Kommunisten einsetzen weder mit Kuba
noch mit Venezuela noch mit Nordkorea
noch mit Nicaragua noch mit
China da habt ihr es also das sind die
sieben großen Unterschiede zwischen
Trump und melee und auch zwischen melee
und bolsonaro und Orban und wie ihr seht
geht es hier nicht um kleine marginale
oder unbedeutende Dinge sondern um
absolut zentrale Themen grundlegende
Pfeiler wenn es darum geht die Art von
Staat zu gestalten für die der eine oder
andere plädiert klar m und Trump haben
einige Überschneidungen bei Themen wie
Klimawandel Waffenkontrolle und
staatliche Regulierungen doch wie ihr
gesehen habt entspringen diese zwei
völlig unterschiedlichen Philosophien
beide treten für vollkommen
unterschiedliche Gesellschaftsmodelle
ein und unabhängig davon ob ihr die
Person m und die Politik für die er
steht mögt oder nicht das Argument er
sei Teil der extremen Rechten wie einige
Journalisten meinen ist nun was wollt
ihr von mir hören es ist absurd wer m
als rechtsextrem bezeichnet sagt damit
viel mehr über sich selbst aus als über
ihnen natürlich ist mil ein Hassobjekt
der Sozialisten und der extremen Linken
er hat versprochen die Staatsausgaben zu
kürzen die Grenzen zu öffnen die Steuern
zu senken und die Zentralbank zu
schließen ihn aber deswegen in einen
Topf mit erzkonservativen oder gar
rechtsradikalen zu werfen zeugt von
nichts anderem als ideologischer
Verblendung und mangelnder politischer
fairnness es handelt sich um Hassrede
und Desinformation in Reinstform denn im
Gegensatz zu rechtsradikalen verteidigt
und fördert die Freiheit und hat kein
Problem mit Geschlecht Herkunft oder
sexueller Orientierung was wir auf jeden
Fall sagen können ist dass er
ultraliberal libertär und
ultrakapitalistisch ist aber
Rechtsextremismus ist nun mal etwas ganz
anderes vor allem ist der
Rechtsextremismus viel sozialistischer
als der Libertarismus weswegen ja eine
der mächtigsten Spielarten des
Rechtsextremismus das unrühmlichste
Kapitel der deutschen Geschichte auch
als
Nationalsozialismus bekannt ist
schließlich ist dieser im Gegensatz zum
Libertarismus durch und durch
kollektivistisch aber was meint ihr wie
würdet ihr mele einordnen was denkt ihr
über diejenigen die ihn als rechtsextrem
einstufen und denkt ihr dass er sich mit
seiner Politik durchsetzen wird wie
immer sind wir auf eure angeregte
Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dies Video
gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht etwas
dabei gelernt habt falls ja gibt i bitte
ein Like falls auch mit euren Freunden
und auf den sozialen Medien natürlich
freuen wir uns auch jederzeit über eine
Spende von euch mit der UN dieses
Projekt weiterzuführen den Link dazu
findet ihr in der beschreib
Video macht's gut und bis
[Musik]
bald